so what what was going on there well
firstly breaking entry to a property
when there's a guest in the property
that's not paying rent is not breaking
the law is completely legal but secondly
I did it deliberately as a stunt because
I knew guaranteed I said to all my
friends that the media would report it
like crazy and make me look like the bad
guy but the interesting thing is if you
go into a shop and you steal something
you go in and steal bread everyone will
say that person deserves to be punished
but for some weird reason you steal from
a landlord or a property owner and then
suddenly it's all right I'm the criminal
I'm the bad guy for evicting that person